here's a fig in Skyfall Naomi and Daniel
you that very sexy potentially dangerous
seeing with the shaving
being shaven now which of you or were I
love you nervous going into that scene
you must have been a bit nervous no I
should practice I did for six weeks yeah
we don't want bleeding extras Joseph
members of the crew who came in and I'd
practice on them really and then lunch
break they liked it trying I have
children
did you do the classic training on a
balloon yes it it mm-hmm that we heard
that you were exceptionally good at
shaving wait at least six weeks so I
think it goes that good okay so could
you still do it if I got you to shave a
balloon could you still do it
okay give it a go all right she's dead
I've got the bits of equipment here to
blow up the balloon we've got to blow up
the balloon can you do that yes Roy
you've got children you must have done
parties it's good it's not as big as
your head is it is doable
here you watching I'll shut my arm this
will be in the next farm field oh yeah
nearly as big as your head keep going
hey that's why right now if you just
want to tie it off and now cuz of you're
the artist I wonder could you put
Daniels face on the balloon very much
lovely it's a pink balloon we're gonna
put shaving foam on it okay are you
confident you won't burst cuz you burst
this we are all to be covered in this
let's go and see you Oh actually it's
below
okay can you can you soap it up if you
want me just open up you can say that
okay okay do it hold it a y-direction
yes thank you very much you done this
before
oh yeah okay I'll put lots on yeah is
that easier to get off that way want to
yes okay won't harder okay so if you
want to stand up just so we shall we do
and I'd say shove down you guys gonna
bring expensive clothes okay
is it are you gonna sit okay well it's
up to you
okay okay I'll hold it for you I'll hold
it for you now are you Oh God
okay this is unbearable just tell
there's a towel there's all right oh
that's hot
okay
it's around the lips that you have to be
really care to believe are you going to
do that you aren't you because I was
trained by the amazing Tony of guy
oh well done you
I think I'm more naturally a horse than
a horse
what hello okay Aloha because that's
what you say it's not Aloha Aloha Aloha